i have to ask avengers in game is that
also your guys marvel end game is there
a world in which you come back
or what what superhero story would you
want to tell next maybe one that's
unheard of i mean i think look
we we prioritize uh quality of life as
much as we prioritize quality of work
and marvel is very high in quality of
life it's a wonderful group of people
had an incredible experience there for
almost a decade so
we would work with them again in a
heartbeat it is as you say
finding the right story what is the
story that we feel compelled to tell
that lines up with the story that they
want to tell and who are the characters
involved in that story and what's unique
about it and different and
um so you know there's a lot that goes
into that and it could take years
to um to do that correctly to dream that
up correctly
um so you know we would never uh
dismiss uh um or forego an opportunity
to work with marvel it just has to line
up with where we are in our careers and
where they're at sometimes i feel like
i've already seen everything that's
gonna happen
and it's a nightmare the audience is
gonna see tom
uh in this movie cherry in a way they're
not used to seeing him they're kind of
used to this
peter parker guy so pretend i didn't see
the movie
tell me what i'm in store for i think
this is
you know this is tom holland in his
first adult role
you know i think this is a transition
for him as an actor and he's exceptional
in it look there's tough material in the
movie there's triggering
material in the film this is meant to be
an unflinching portrait
of a drug addiction uh and uh
and tom uh um you know physically and
emotionally shredded himself for the
part
yeah yeah i was just i was talking to
him earlier he said you like to
exaggerate it to 30 pounds but it was
really 27 and a half pounds
did it take any convincing to to get tom
on board i imagine when you guys sign on
to something
any anybody in their right mind is going
to say yes but did it take any
convincing to get tom to
play this character because he makes so
many bad choices but we still
root for this guy man from first frame
to last frame
i love that you pointed that out about
time because that that is so tom he was
like
he will not indulge any kind of
overstatement whatsoever he's very
it's very humble he's very very direct
um
you know look we developed a very deep
relationship with tom over the years as
you can imagine you know
casting him as a spider-man was a very
involved process there's hundreds of
actors it was
it was a difficult role to cast but once
we saw tom
audition we recognized something in him
that we really responded to
strongly and we began working with him
intensely from that moment on
first to get him the role and then over
the course of three films of spider-man
and multiple years you know we developed
a very deep working relationship with
him he has a really
sophisticated understanding of us who we
are as people who we are as artists
we have a very sophisticated
understanding of who he is as an artist
and a person
and i think that there's a high level of
trust between us
and also we share we share uh we share a
similar
sort of inclination toward pushing
ourselves
uh into areas that make us uh into
unknown areas as artists
and so i think all of that wrapped
together tom was game for this right
from the beginning he knew you know i
think
tom saw it as a strong sign that if we
believed
that this role was right for him that it
that that there was something in it that
was
that was right for him and so he
embraced the role very early on
and with a lot of excitement a lot of
passion
and and a lot of seriousness you know he
he took it
very seriously he worked extremely hard
and i you know i think in a lot of ways
the role was intimidating for him
because
he doesn't have this sort of life
experience that
that that this this character does
having gone to war
being lost in the depths of drug
addiction
but tom really did the work to figure
out what that means on the most intimate
level to him
as a person and how to translate it to
the screen and he just blew us all away
boy did he i mean that is an
understatement blew us away i mean
him and sierra just absolutely crush
this thing you ride this fine line of
balance in between
humor and this almost ethereal score
dealing with these
dark topics was that difficult balancing
all that stuff
it is difficult i think that you know
one thing that isn't talked enough about
i think in film schools and about
directing in general is that
tone is the most important part of a
film it's also
you know the easiest way to fail is if
you you misfire on the tone
this has a complex tone it's where aunt
and i thrive on shows like
development of community we love
complicated tones
um we like being mad scientists and
mixing together genres and
humor with dark humor with drama and
you're shaking it all up to see what
you've come up with and you have to
manage that
from the first word of the script to the
last edit in the edit room and that's
part of the
you know challenge of it and part of
what excites us as filmmakers
yeah i got to tell you i'm infatuated
with film and this is
really a delight to watch this thing
your emotions are struck in so many
different directions so
constantly i absolutely loved it now you
guys are working on an upcoming film the
gray man with with
gosling and anna de armas and captain
america himself chris evans so do we
is this what we get from the russo
brothers now a little a little more
marvel
superheroes in non-marvel movies joe and
i throughout our careers look we started
off as like
very low budget experimental
indie filmmakers you know that segwayed
into television with drama and comedy
and big movies then after that
like we shoot commercials we love the
entire variety and the entire range of
what you can do as
as a storyteller as a filmmaker so we'll
constantly i think throughout our
careers keep pushing ourselves into new
directions but
certainly with the gray man we're going
to be exploring a genre
the spy genre which has been a favorite
of ours throughout our lives
and we're doing it yes we're doing it
with some actors that we
incredibly admire both ones that we have
never worked with before and and really
fortunately
in chris evans some that we have worked
with before so it's a really exciting
movie for us
it's in uh if you're a fan of uh captain
america the winter soldier
which had elements of this genre in it
this is us going
a full bore in the gray man